Je veux faire équipe comme Batman ou Robin
personne ne veut être Robin qu'est-ce qui ne va pas
avec Robin aimeriez-vous que Robin de Big Daddy d'
accord Robin souhaite qu'il soit moi ce que
j'essaie de dire, c'est que nous devrions être partenaires
vous et moi comme le duo dynamique I  Je suis dans
la NFL Dave tu joues au p-wing alors entraîne moi
je veux marcher la marche tu es la
chose la plus proche que je connaisse d'un vrai super-héros
comment es-tu fatigué d'être tout seul
tu ne veux pas savoir que quelqu'un est là
pour toi quelqu'un qui te soutient
et tu feras n'importe quoi je dis n'importe quoi
me frappe tu es une fille de 15 ans
qu'est-ce que tu fais comme une chienne tu te fais
gifler comme une chienne Oh mon Dieu